right springing babe Laufenberg the
Cowboys radio network analyst and former
NFL quarterback good morning babe how is
morale there in Texas well where else
good here because I'm in my house so I
woke up had a little coffee so now it's
just great here now once I get up to the
star where the Cowboys practice facility
is might be a little different what did
you take away from yesterday's game um
it was it was a very strange game and
one thing the Cowboys have always been
ready to play under Jason Garrett that I
can only think of a couple of times
where they came out you know and just
didn't look like I want to say
themselves but the lack of a better word
didn't look like themselves happened a
couple years ago in Denver where they
just kind of failed to show up but it
hasn't happened under Jason Garrett's
watch and yes they just you know they
was interesting because they were able
to move the football but then they kind
of bogged down a couple of sacks on
third down they'd only given up three
sacks all year but they had a few in
this game and then obviously the
turnovers and the early turnover they
had you know dak Prescott Scout Amari
Cooper deep and ball bounced off the
shoulders and Green Bay intercepts they
turned that into a touchdown so just
kind of was a strange feeling game
including all the way to the end I mean
they're down 31 3 yeah with 3 minutes
and 30 seconds to go in the 3rd quarter
and it's if I wasn't a fan I'd have been
long gone but listen to me on the radio
by the way and then all of a sudden it
became game yeah but babe should we over
reactor under react based off what
happened yesterday and what happened in
New Orleans against the sings well as I
say the history of the NFL was written
week to week so they were the greatest
thing ever
in weeks through through three weeks on
and they had not played obviously great
football teams they had the Giants in
the open and in Washington and Miami and
in fact you said argue you know two of
the worst teams in the league and then
one that hadn't been very good at that
point but yeah it's a long season you
know this team was three and five last
year and everybody obviously wanted to
head coach fire things turn around they
get Amari Cooper at the halfway point
and they go on to win the division so
you know I've been around it long enough
obviously that I just know it's a long
season and things that you think in the
first half of the season
that you know for a fact become non
facts by the second half of the season
people turn things around and they have
played they had played you know a really
good defense and they've got the
defensive players but they kind of got
gassed on the ground a little bit
yesterday by Aaron Jones in the running
game I mean you expect Aaron Rodgers to
do his thing but I don't think they
expected there and Jones to go in
average five and a half yard to carry
what do you make of this column in the
Fort Worth star-telegram by Clarence
Hill fraudulent arrogant Cowboys guilty
of sniffing themselves now facing
reality check well first and foremost as
you will know down the the rider does
not write to headline but sniffing
themselves would not be something that I
was an editor that I would put into my
newspaper but I I have not read no
Clarence know him well well he did write
this so here's his first couple of lines
yeah yeah my point is I haven't seen it
yet so go ahead okay what do you call a
supposed Super Bowl contender who only
has victories against bad teams losses
to the good teams fraudulent period
suspect period fake period so Clarence
didn't write the headline but but yeah
well it's funny because the whole
suitable notion I mean it's a long
season and it's am I've been I was a
team military and it's been sense for
them for a long time you'd be the first
to tell you and I'm I know you've had
him on the show any Super Bowls hard
hard to get do they're hard to win it's
hard he'll be the first to tell you even
though it kind of looked easy for him
right he won three of them I look at you
know the notion of the Super Bowl right
you this team's Super Bowl team and if
they don't put a Super Bowl Jason
Garrett's getting fired
the guy yesterday Aaron Rodgers has
played 14 years in the league he's been
to one suitable yeah he's a surefire
hall-of-famer we all know that he's been
to one your Brees has been 18 years in
league this is 19th year he's been the
one into one so the notion that you're
you know dak Prescott if he doesn't get
to the Super Bowl you don't give them a
big money I mean it's it's trying to get
there a lot of things you have to go
right for him
again I just always go back to Dan it's
a it's a long season
it's
sixteen weeks and what you think in week
five it will not be what we think and we
can which won't be what we think when
the playoffs it's um but yeah the whole
fraudulent notion it's like I always say
people say hey do you think this team is
underrated or that guy is underrated
I still I don't know it depends on how
you rate them so if you had the Cowboys
winning the Superbowl at the beginning
of the year yeah they're failing
I didn't I didn't have them there I had
them as a contender and they are still a
contender but maybe bottom line clearly
this isn't a revelation you go minus 3
then the turnover differential you even
lose about 90% of those football games
and that's exactly what they did
yesterday went minus 3 and they lost the
game Jason Garrett Stannis he doesn't
get that extension yet do you feel like
there is he must get to here to keep his
job is there is there a line of
demarcation for Jason Garrett to keep
his job you know what let me at Dan hold
on one second I've got Jerry Jones on
line two ok fair enough let me add here
me all right no he's the only one
everybody speculates on what Jason needs
to do but I do know that Jerry Jerry
really likes Jason they worked well
together the last thing he wants to do
is fired Jason now does that mean it
won't happen it doesn't mean it won't
happen but I do know this Jerry's going
to try to do everything he can to make
that work and you know the extension was
interesting there's a lack of extension
I should say you know everybody took
that as a sign and Jason's coaching for
his job well shoot as you well know
other than Bill Belichick everybody's
coaching for the job ok we found out
that he he was coaching first job
yesterday and he kind of knew it but so
the notion that Jason's going to work
harder
I hate to say that sounds like some name
dropping here but I've been I've been
friends with Jason for 25 years I know
I'm very well we're good friends been
good friends sound like Jason and good
friends for a long time but it doesn't
motivate him that he doesn't he needs
another contract that's not I can just
guarantee you that's not the way he's
wired he goes in there if he has a
contract fine if he doesn't that's just
the way he goes about his life he truly
I know coaches love
the mantra of we're going to stake today
in this game but that's the way he goes
through his life and all aspects of it
babe good to talk to you you and Brad
make a great team it was a really
enjoyable listen yesterday not being
able to watch the game at some point but
listening to the game on the radio oh
well I appreciate it very much and Brad
and anybody makes a good team you know
it's just like Pat Summerall or Al
Michaels and whoever may they make a
really good key so but I appreciate it
very much thank you nice to be on the
show thank you babe that's babe
Laufenberg Cowboys radio network analyst
in Brad sham